Speaker 1: OK. Wow. Wow. Let's go next
to Eduardo from Brooklyn, New York.
Speaker 4: Hi, David, how are you? I'm doing well.
Thanks for taking my call. I, you know, obviously
watching everything that's going on, I have like a
more sort of wide macro vision of things that are
going on. And the question I have for you is,
is there any sort of entity or anybody that's
kind of taking task of like all these ruby
cards that will keep crossing that we're not
going to be able to come back from?
Speaker 1: Give me some what like
what examples are you referring to?
Speaker 4: I mean, just the, you know,
best example coming top of my head is, you know.
The idea of like claiming anything that doesn't
agree with you is fake news and things like
that. I think that's a Rubicon that got crossed.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I agree. I don't disagree with
you. That's become I mean, I think there's a
couple. One is the acceptable treatment of any
media you don't like in this completely hostile
way that Trump started with Jim Acosta and CNN
calling any news that's critical. Fake news
questioning the results of any election.
When you don't like the results, you say
that the election was rigged. That's sort of
a Rubicon that I feel has been crossed. Yeah,
I to your question. I don't see the Republican
Party backing off of those tactics anytime
soon. I think they're here to stay.
Speaker 4: Right? But you know, my my
question really is like, are we keeping track
of those so that like maybe if we, I don't know,
say cross three Republicans, you know, like one
will get through because we didn't, you know,
there's so many going on at the same time.
Speaker 1: I mean, listen, we're trying to
we're trying to. And I think, you know, one of
the good things that happened last week on the
anniversary of January 6th was a whole bunch of
people wrote articles saying the insurrection
and coup, it's not really over. They're going to
keep trying. A Jimmy Carter wrote a piece and,
you know, a bunch of people. Noam Chomsky was
interviewed about it. So I think there's an effort
being made to keep track, but it is really tough.
Speaker 4: Now, I and I appreciate, you know,
you've all like yourself, you know, fair and
all the more those guys, you know, like they,
you know, they keep people to task. I just worry
that like you just, you know, it's a part of like
more of an Echo like Echo Buxton. Yeah, you know,
but they would, you know, keep on doing what you
do and I appreciate all your effort.
Speaker 1: Thank you so much and I
appreciate you calling in. We're
going to take some more calls,
but we'll first take a very short break.
If you're holding on to talk to me
and you still want to talk to me. Don't
hang up. We're going to be right back